you ready  i'm ready  nice knowing you spider-man but excuse  me  the entire world's about to forget that  peter parker is spider-man everyone  uh can't some people still know that's  not how the spell works so my  girlfriend's just gonna forget about  everything we've been through i mean is  she even gonna be my girlfriend all  right fine  everyone in the world is gonna forget  that you're spiderman except your  girlfriend thank you so much that  oh my nick okay let's not change the  parameters of this spell anymore while  i'm okay i'm done i'm done i swear i'm  done i'm done  now but my aunt may should really know  did you just stop talking  [Music]  you